are you currently filming AGT right now
I'm doing cgt which Canada's Got Talent
amazing and we just finished AGT
All-Stars and then at the end of March I
start AGT again so I'm like at a I'm in
like a whirlwind I don't know last night
I was in Miami
I don't know where and what were you
doing out there I don't know it's just
uh your show I don't know I don't know I
don't know what I'm doing here fear I
just don't know thanks for saying it out
loud man because we all look at each
other being like who is this guy yeah I
don't know how did he get here I don't
know what wait how Canada what do they
bring to the table that America's not uh
stepping up to the plate with are you
really yeah Justin Trudeau
Justin Bieber Cirque du Soleil sure
Justin Bieber sure every movie you've
ever loved Gretzky okay here's what
America's got Tony Robbins Will Smith
Pillsbury Doughboy Fresca Fresco yeah